welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness dealt a
devastating blow to anyone who has ever
said i could do this all day when the
scarlet witch said good night to that
i could watch this sequence all day
screenwriter michael waldron said in the
audio commentary about this moment i
have to imagine that moment hurts wanda
she was so close to steve she would have
known peggy or known of her but i don't
know it doesn't really look like it
hurts wanda that much does it she's like
thank you next thank you
and i think the reason we're able to
detach from peggy's death here is that
more than the other members of the
illuminati we know peggy's coming back
in some form in the mcu as the lead
variant of marvel's animated what if
series there's just something about this
shield that whether it's star spangled
or union jacked well polished or
dripping with blood as it is here we
know cats keep bouncing back to do this
all day captain carter's death here is
not the end of her it's really the
beginning of something else and in this
episode of feige's plan i'm going to
talk about how marvel studios decision
to make captain america a shared
responsibility from the very beginning
set them up perfectly as they now
explore multiversal networks like the
captain britain core while some viewers
may have felt a bit let down by the
limited scope of multiverse of madness's
multiverse exploration the film did make
a very important contribution to the mcu
with one line from christine palmer in
the 838 universe our universe is 838 and
we've designated yours 616. 616 of
course the numerical designation of the
primary universe of marvel comics and a
matter that only matters when you're
gonna start introducing other numbers
and we should know that the origin of
that number actually came from captain
britain comics in the 80s credited to
ellen moore and alan davis but actually
coined by writer david thorpe in the
captain britain's storylines thorpe
realized that captain britain would need
to exist in an alternate universe with a
network of other caps from across the
multiverse and it would just be easier
to give these earths numerical
designations so he came up first with
616 by starting with 666 the number of
the beast minus 50.
i love that fact so that's how we got
616 and we have thorpe and a multiversal
network of caps to thank for it this is
why i'm so excited to see captain carter
appear in the same mcu title that
formally codifies the mcu at 616 with a
baxter foundation studying the
multiverse because it suggests that not
only will this 838 captain carter be
avenged by the surviving avengers of
this reality but that she leaves behind
a multiverse full of caps who can do
this all day remember how our friend
drax said that every being in the
universe is either one who dances or one
who doesn't and in the multiverse that
is also true some people are singular
figures who never want to meet their
alternate selves and some folks cannot
wait to connect and dance with their
alternate selves remember multiverse of
madness establishes dreams is just
peering into the lives of our variants
and if you're the kind of person who
wakes up screaming non-dancer but if you
wake up thinking no just a bit longer
you my friend are a dancer and you need
a multiverse of use spider-man in the
comics definitely a multiversal dancer
reed richards totally a multiversal
dancer nathaniel richards and kang oh
yeah they're hitting that multiversal
dance floor in captain america well we
have already seen two caps dancing right
but years before the multiverse was even
a thought under kevin feige's ball cap
captain america was defined in the mcu
as a cooperative figure a sum of parts a
living embodiment of the american ideal
of e pluribus unum out of many one
captain america was never just steve
rogers he was an ideal made up of
several contributors steve provided the
heart and the spirit and definitely the
face and we later learned that ass
abraham erskine provided the super
soldier serum howard stark provided the
suit and the gear the wakandans
technically provided the shield since it
was made of vibranium and steve's great
loves of peggy carter and bucky barnes
lit the fire cap has never been a
singular hero but a leader of a pack a
member of a team whether it's the 100
first airborne division the howling
commandos the avengers and yeah as we're
saying in alternate universes the
guardians of the multiverse or the
illuminati in past episodes we talked
about how thor's brokenness and
unworthiness are embodied in his weapon
mjolnir and for cap his spiritual totem
is his shield captain america's shield
has become sort of an american excalibur
but unlike the parallels between mjolnir
and that arthurian blade the shield is a
defensive tool it protects and cradles
it does get weaponized in later films
but specifically as a non-lethal
alternative to cap using a firearm now
yeah sure the way he throws that shield
around it probably would crack some
necks but still you know they intend it
to be non-lethal and you may have
noticed how one ace in the hole that
marvel studios keeps returning to is the
way they share these heroes totems it's
never really been about cap brandishing
the shield by himself that's not really
that exciting it's really the times he
uses them in tandem with another
avengers power set and the times that he
exchanges the shield in the time that
someone else holds it like bucky
catching the shield and winter soldier
yeah
a spider-man snatching that shield in
civil war whoa
cap leaving the shield behind in civil
war
t'challa saying get this man a shield
yes cap handing off the shield and end
game
wow
and yes we can totally interpret the
falcon in the winter soldier not as the
story of any one of these characters but
really the story of that shield how it
was unfairly taken how is defaced how it
was briefly held by the wakandans and of
course how it returned to its rightful
owner this way the shield more than
mjolnir or iron man's armor or
spider-man suit has never belonged to
any one person it has always been from
the beginning a shared responsibility of
a collective and that is what the
captain britain core is a collective of
shield bearers led by brian braddock
captain britain a guy who was name
dropped to actually be listened
carefully to avengers end game therefore
brian braddock exists in the 616 so he
probably exists in other universes in
one of them he probably carries a shield
but the mcu's council of caps doesn't
have to be led by brian braddock it very
well could just be led by another
captain carter like the one who is now
the focal character of what if so we
have another captain carter in one
universe we got sam wilson captain
america in the 616 universe and there
have been some unconfirmed reports that
chris evans was at least in talks to
return to steve rogers in a future title
most recently chris evans told
comicbook.com it would have to be
perfect and what would be more perfect
than getting to fight as captain rogers
alongside captain carter and captain
wilson and what threat would they face
well multiverse of madness might have
given us an answer to that too it
established the existence of a hydra
universe the hydra logo appearing on a
blimp over 1930s new york and i've
speculated how logically red skull would
be the one leading this hydra and as we
saw in what if episode 1 red skull has a
side to him that's very eager to venture
into alternate dimensions and would be
something of a multiversal threat when
left unchecked multiversal hydra versus
multiversal core of caps admit it it
sounds perfect and we could watch it all
day
oh brother this guy stinks let me know
your thoughts on this below you can
follow me on instagram and twitter hey
thoughts follow me rockstars subscribe
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you